what do you do if you're a professor at
a leading Russian University and
speaking honestly about the Putin regime
brings threats of investigation and
prosecution from the authorities in 2013
Sergei curry F chose self-exile and
France after being interrogated
repeatedly for criticizing the Putin
administration's treatment of Mikhail
Khodorkovsky a Russian oil tycoon now at
sea on SPO in Paris
professor curry have sat down with
resident scholar Leon Aaron at the
American Enterprise Institute to discuss
the Russian economy the tactics of
modern autocrats and why he has no plans
to return to Russia what do you think is
happening with the Russian economy why
and what are the implications for the
region I think today Russian economy is
actually facing a perfect storm in a
sense that there are several headwinds
that are that are blowing at the very
same time one being the lack of reform
they slow down due to the bad investment
climate high corruption intervention of
the state that slowed down in stagnation
has actually started before Crimean
crisis and on top of that there is a low
oil price just a year ago nobody would
have believed that oil prices can go
below $50 per barrel or stabilized at 60
or slowly above 60 this is something
that is a dramatic event for Russian
economy and on top of that is the
sanctions the the impact of the
sanctions which have been introduced
last year and these things reinforce
each other if not for the sanctions low
oil price would be a problem but a
temporary problem Russia would be able
to sit out of the market or borrow with
the sanctions Russia cannot borrow and
therefore it has to spend the reserve
fund and at the moment if you look at
the budget at the speed at which reserve
fund is being spent the regime has
couple of years but probably not more in
couple of years the regime will have to
reckon which other expenditures to cut
and that may have dramatic political
implications in principle the government
is very happy to say that Russian public
is ready to suffer but I think we've not
yet seen the real cuts we've not yet
seen the real here
on the economy and once incomes go down
substantially Russian public will start
to choose whether to believe the TV or
the fridge as they said the insulating
tell me you know Hadar Kowski has been
pardoned by Putin and you were harassed
maybe it's a milder term for what what's
happening to you in connection
presumably with the third preparation
for the third trial of Mikhail
Khodorkovsky we cut our course key in
exile but free is is there any reason
for you to stay out of Russia and what's
your sense on this the interesting part
of this story is that what Heather
Costas has been pardoned the case which
has been started in which was started in
2003 is still open and we occasionally
hear news that this case is supposed to
be closed but still opened and by
Russian law no case can stay open for
more than ten years but what happens to
this case every quarter it gets renewed
it gets prolonged and in that sense I'm
still a witness in this case and I'm
still I'm still not sure whether I can
return to Russia or not and on top of
that that's been a number of other
signals that I got that I maybe also
disliked by the region because they've
publicly supported mr. Novotny
may have also been disliked by the
region because I spoke I spoke
reasonably openly about the
imperfections of Russian political
system which is let's put it mildly less
than democratic you published a very
interesting article called new
authoritarianism and the essence as I
understood it is this there is a new
kind of authoritarianism in other words
you don't have to kill people they don't
have to feel many people you don't have
to put many people in jail it's enough
to manipulate symbols it's enough to
manipulate information it's not enough
to manipulate the truth I assume that
you feel that the current Russian regime
falls into that category could you talk
more about this this paper covers new
regimes not only the Russian regime but
also some other regimes of which we
think the first regime was Fujimori's
government in Peru but there are some
other countries which also feed this
description now around China
some extent turkey Hungary Venezuela
some people who suggest other countries
but Russia certainly fits this
description and basically the game of a
new autocrat is not to kill people
because when you kill people you signal
that you have to kill people that means
that you're weak you're incompetent and
your power is only based on on on the
force on the brutal force well the
current autocracy the new autocracy is
based on information they don't force
people into accepting the autocracy they
try to convince people to like them and
in order to do that they use massive
propaganda and I think we still
underestimate the impact of today's
propaganda in Russia Russia I think goes
beyond any historical precedents in
terms of investing a lot of resources in
making it effective and comprehensive
but on top of that of course Russia is
not a closed country there are many
people who understand what's going on
and with those informed citizens the
regime has to deal with through other
instruments through competition bribes
or material benefits all through
censorship and the balance between these
instruments is exactly what we consider
and study in this paper and going back
to the issue of the fridge I think the
most important issue that we talk about
in this paper is all these things cost
money
and eventually the regime has to choose
whether to spend on public goods so
people feel happier or on information
and we show that eventually all these
regimes will probably collapse at some
point but they may still survive for
quite a while in one surprising result
that we find is these regimes may
survive even when consumption levels are
going down and moreover they can become
even more popular along with the
following living and living standards is
it possible that Putin very skillfully
after election 2012 began to shift the
basis of regime's legitimacy from this
constant growth in real incomes
to what might be called patriotic
mobilization I think you're exactly
right and we are trying to make this
point in this academic paper as well we
argue that the regime's which are
actually switched to equilibria with
cooperation and propaganda and then
there are regimes which are based on
censorship and propaganda and I think we
saw as Russian regime switched around
this time and you mentioned 2012-2013
from one based on distributing handy now
the benefits of economic growth to the
middle-class into becoming more
censorship based and indeed we are not
really sure to what extent Crimean
adventure or crisis started because
Russian economy stopped to grow maybe it
was just indeed an accident but that was
a very fortunate accident for mr. Putin
if you actually go back to mr. nemtsov's
analytical work on Ukrainian war which
was just published by posthumously by
his colleagues a few days ago you can
see that he starts with this electoral
approval rent ratings of mr. Putin
electoral ratings which were sliding
down as economic growth was sliding down
and that that stagnation are actually
declining there in ratings was reversed
by the Crimean Adventure and of course
even if it was an accident that was a
very nice coincidence for mr. Putin to
grab this accident and to use it to take
advantage of this opportunity to grab
some somebody else's land to become more
popular I don't think it's it can go on
answering your question I don't think it
can go on for many many years but it
certainly is possible that we will see a
few years of the Syrian regime using
using the benefits of this or this
territorial expansion we didn't made
this choice that he is willing to take
the cost of sanctions because this
perennial tension with Ukraine this
perennial tension with the West gives
him I think makes up in certain in
certain way for the for the economic
downturn
in terms of regime's legitimacy is that
is that how you view it this is exactly
the case I think mr. Putin made this
conscious choice he saw that economic
growth is unlikely to return anyway and
so he used this foreign policy as input
for propaganda he needs to explain to
Russian public why incomes are falling
and having an enemy as because if the
United States then explains why
inflation is high and incomes are not
growing and if you compare that to
previous foreign policy tensions like
things happening around Estonia or
Poland or Georgia in early years of
Putin's regime these are not big enough
to explain why incomes are not growing
and actually are falling if you actually
say that this is the US which is our
enemy that may explain quite a bit
however I think we will see that the
propaganda impact of annexing Crimea
will fade away and if mr. Putin starts
implementing means to agreement that
will be a backlash in a sense that the
public will see that his week and he is
not competent when he entered East
Ukraine he did not calculate to what
extent sanctions can cure it and I think
this is something which will be very
humiliating yet I can see how East
Ukraine will be a frozen conflict at
least I don't see how it's completely
abandoned by mr. Putin but I also attach
zero probability to the event that
Crimea will be returned to to Ukraine
under mr. Putin's watch I think it's
unthinkable for mr. Putin to return
Crimea and in that sense I think some
sanctions will stay
what can the West do I think you rightly
identified the battleground I think the
battleground is not actually in your
grade it's it's in Russia as in Russia
and it's in the Russian television in a
sense it's in Russian public's Minds
it's the information war much more than
its a conventional war and I think if
the West wants to win
hearts and minds of Russian public the
West has to speak to Russians and to
explain why mr. Putin is incompetent why
his policy is actually destroying
Russia's future what happened to the to
this up swelling of you know for the
lack of better term you know the
middle-class protests I think I think it
was repressed I think the right word is
repression
I think the regime made a huge mistake
because there was an opportunity to
divest the non democratic institutions
and move slowly into the direction of
democracy in the regime went the other
way which means the regime destroyed its
own exit options which i think is very
dangerous for the regime and I can only
be sorry for the top people in the
government right now but I think
eventually a democracy will come to
Russia and the very people that you
mentioned whether they are now in prison
under house arrest outside of Russia or
whether they're temporarily accepting or
believe in Putin's propaganda I think
that will come back simply because you
can stop you can stop march of history
you cannot as President Lincoln once
said I once said you can lie to some
people for for a long time you can
deceive everybody but for a short time
but you cannot deceive everybody forever
how quickly can Russia
replenish the the reservoirs of of
social capital public goods this is
something pretty precious and this does
not easily come back this is the key
issue and I think democracy cannot
really exist and develop without trust
from people between people without trust
in institutions the the point of Frank
Fukuyama makes exactly exactly and I
think we don't know I think we see such
an unprecedented attack on civil society
which is going on in Russia mainly
within people's hands we don't we we
don't have a precedent in history of
such an aggressive and comprehensive
propaganda I think if we go back to
1930s in Germany you can see Nazi radio
which will has been extremely effective
but that was just audio now Russian TV
which is extremely well-funded also adds
visuals and I think humans are
physiologically not able to be
critically perceiving what they see on
TV if you see it in your own eyes it's
very hard for you to reject the notion
that this is true and I think humans are
still to grow up and reject Putin's
propaganda I think that that will take
some time and maybe the the process of
deep brainwashing will take longer than
we can expect you were a professor in
Russia and that matters because you were
essentially in touch in daily touch with
I think we could probably call them the
the the Russian young elite would think
of them I mean where are they in all of
this well in the new kind of school the
situation was indeed not representative
we based we build the school around
military police we fought
cheating and plagiarism we encouraged
meritocracy and hard work and people who
prospered in that environment went on to
meritocratic professional careers either
in Russia or in the in the West but
indeed what you said is correct I think
there are several factors which have
contributed to cynicism of the young
generation one is of course propaganda
which started in 2000 another thing is
of course this propaganda was effective
on the young generation because the
young generation did not see how Soviet
Union functioned
so there's there's this this
mythological image exactly nobody can
believe that you couldn't actually buy
whatever sausage or toilet paper and the
young generation just doesn't understand
to what extent Soviet Union collapsed
because it was intrinsically incompetent
in bankrupt they would think that maybe
there were some old incompetent people
who he
trained well they would run Soviet Union
in the right way or all the plots by the
West or the plots by the West exactly
and another thing is of course
corruption which prospers in Russian
educational institutions so when people
in their formative years enter
educational institutions but if you look
at surveys you see that about half of
Russian students actually encounter
corruption first firsthand and when you
are 18 to 24 years old we know from
psychological literature that's when you
become personality and if at that age
you understand that everything can be
bought and sold the shortcuts really
work principals don't really matter then
you become cynical and that creates a
new new ground for corrupt practices
later and I think this is the goal of
the regime to promote this feeling that
Russia has no future without Putin's
hierarchy even though it's not actually
working out that well basically the
message is if Putin is gone there will
be no Russian